Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this
episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
The first 1,000 people to click
the link in the description
can get a 1 month free trial of
Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
If you have a cat, you have probably witnessed
them chasing down the insects and spiders and
other crawly creatures that live in your
home. Our master of microscopes, James,
has two cats. And so he is the beneficiary
of their combined hunting prowess.
So James decided to turn that
bounty over to the microscope,
and to see how these familiar creatures
look when we see them up close,
and also to see what autofluorescence they
reveal when we use our fluorescent light.
Now, this is a bit different than our usual path
into more microbial realms, where little droplets
of water reveal new worlds and new creatures.
Instead this time, we’re looking at creatures
who are quite visible and even familiar.
But it’s always fun to see familiar sights
in unfamiliar ways, and to see what
else there might be there to learn.
For example, let’s talk about the silverfish.
Now, if you don’t recognize that name, maybe
the silverfish sounds like an elegant creature
you’d find swimming in a fantastical river.
But in reality they are those tiny, wingless
insects that you find scurrying around in
humid spots like your bathroom. And our
homes are full of their favorite foods,
whether that’s the glue binding a book together,
wallpaper, or dry food in our pantries.
And unfortunately we don’t have footage of the
next thing we’re about to tell you, but it’s the
kind of thing that when you learn it, you have
to share it.. The silverfish you are looking at
right now might be remarkably still, but that
stillness... conceals the heart of a dancer.
When it comes time for reproduction, male and
female silverfish have a whole routine that they
work through. They begin by facing each other
and tapping their antenna against each other,
before backing away. And then they repeat
this, coming closer and then coming apart
until the male silverfish runs away. Then the
female tracks him down, and when she does,
they lay head-to-tail—vibrating with reproductive
intent. The male will deposit a sperm capsule
on the ground, the female will
pick it up. And from there a new
generation of crawling silverfish will be born.
Unfortunately, we do not have a fun story like
that to tell about this spider for the very simple
reason that we don’t know what kind of spider it
is. All we know about it is what you can see: it
is tiny and green with little bits of white hair.
And its eyes! If you hate spiders, maybe
those eyes are scary, but we think they’re
actually really lovely and a little endearing.
We also know that this was quite the lucky
spider because it was not killed by James’ cats,
which is why you can see it moving around…unlike
this unfortunate spider, which met its end before
we put it under the microscope, but it seems to be
twitching a bit when we turn the UV light on.
Now we didn’t put our mystery green friend
under the UV light in case that
might’ve fried it to death.
Instead James decided to release it, so hopefully
it is now off living a wonderful life somewhere.
But we would love to know
what kind of spider it is,
so if any of you know anything that can help us
identify it, please let us know in the comments!
Now, this, however, is part of a very
familiar insect. These are the little
fuzzy hairs on a housefly’s butt.
And here, up close, are its wings,
with hints of iridescence popping against the
dark background. That color is not the result
of pigments. It’s a structure inside the wing
itself that bounce light back in a way that
produces the multifaceted, filmy color we see.
And when we turn the fluorescent light on, that
iridescence goes away, but the patterns of veins
running through the wings becomes more apparent.
If we travel further down, we get to one
of the fly’s feet, which has some strange
autofluorescence at the side. Now, we’re
not entomologists, but our guess is that
the autofluorescence is connected to structures
in the feet that help the fly taste their food.
That’s right. Flies taste with their feet. As
they’re flying around and landing on potential
food, they use the taste receptors on their
feet to get a sense of whether their landing
spot is actually edible. Unfortunately, of course
those edible landing spots happen to be my food,
or yours, but mostly I’m concerned about mine.
Now, flies however are a much less threatening
household pest compared to this one: the scorpion.
Now just to reassure you: there was no cat versus
scorpion showdown to bring you this image.
This scorpion was a souvenir, preserved and
bought in Thailand, and then brought to James’
home by the previous tenants of that home.
And when we turn on the UV light, almost
the entire scorpion seems to turn blue.
It’s a handy trick for finding scorpions
in the dark: just shine a black light,
and you’ll find them glowing around you.
But it’s not clear exactly what chemical causes
this neon shine, just that whatever chemical
it is, it’s located in an outer layer of the
scorpion’s exoskeleton. That is why scorpions that
have molted and are still growing out their new,
tough exoskeleton will not fluoresce.
Now, why does the scorpion do this?
We don’t really know, but one possibility is that
it turns the scorpion into a giant UV sensor,
able to detect UV light even when it's nighttime
so that it can find darker places to hide in.
And from one stinger to another, let’s
end with every picnic’s favorite insect:
the bee. Only the familiar yellow and black colors
have been rendered into a more
orange and teal combination here.
This image of its eyes seems even more abstract,
but maybe that’s fitting because bee eyes…well,
they see things differently than we do.
They can’t see red, but they can see in
the ultraviolet spectrum. And so just as the way
that we look through the microscope changes the
world that we see, an animal’s eyes change the
world it sees. There are flowers with distinctive
patterns painted in ultraviolet, a world that
will always remain abstract and invisible to
us. It’s a world layered on our own, imagined with
a vocabulary that can never fully do it justice.
But not all visions are meant to be seen
by us. Sometimes it’s enough to just know
that they exist, and to bring what little
parts of them we can into our own world.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We’d also like to again thank
Skillshare for supporting this video.
Now that you’ve been up close and
personal with some insects and arachnids,
and have this new knowledge of all of
the details that make up their bodies,
Skillshare is here to help you
put that knowledge to good use!
With courses like Insect Illustrations
and Animations in Procreate,
you can create beautiful images of your
favorite insects, and artist Liz Kohler Brown
will walk you through the process.
You’ll play around with colors and
layouts that work for your personal style
in order to create an insect illustration,
and then you’ll go a step further to learn
how to actually animate that illustration.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
With so much to explore, real world projects
to create, and the support of fellow-creatives,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth. It’s curated specifically for learning,
meaning there are no ads to distract you, and
they’re always launching new premium classes,
so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you.
And if you’re one of the first 1,000 people
to click on the link in the description,
you can get a 1 month free trial
of Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
Now, you might be asking yourself. How
does a channel like this exist on YouTube?
Where there’s like chill narration and chill music
and chill visuals. It’s not like big and flashy
like a lot of what goes on on this platform.
Well, the reason that we can do this is
because there are people who really like it
and some of those people, when they can, they help
us out at patreon.com/journeytomicro. And these
are those people. The people who make it possible
for us to do this, and we are so grateful to them.
If you want to see more from our
Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
you can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram,
and if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.